ils sont là en catimini mais pas pour
longtemps parmi les passagers de ce bus
en direction des l'encours des poètes
l'herbe dit vous ne fait aucun bruit
pour pousser l'enfant pour grandir le
temps pour passer l la brigade quand ils
en vendent lancé l'embuscade poétique
nous on est plus spécialisé pour aller
aux gens à la personne lors faire ce
petit cadeau du poème qu'on leur donne à
titre personnel avec une carte où ils
peuvent re lire des d'autres poèmes des
mots susurrer à l'oreille des passagers
du réseau stibus c'est la troisième
année que les artistes investissent les
transports en commun pour le printemps
des poètes le projet il s'agit de mettre
la poésie accessible à toutes et à tous
et un des endroits les plus
emblématiques c'est bien les transports
publics donc on travaille avec ski bus
et donc on propose aux voyageurs
l'écoutent de poèmes ou donnés par des
compagnies théâtrales dont content bande
d'elancourt et les profs d'histoire de
paris une quinzaine de comédiens a
sillonné les limes saint-quentinoise
pour ensoleiller cette journée grisâtre